most people make the decision whether
they want to stay with your company
between the sale and the first call so
like not even when they've tried your
product just through their experience
between when they were sold and what
their first real touch point is with the
company how they've been treated during
that period of time they've made their
decision of whether or not they want to
stay with you what are some of your
favorite things to do between sale we
send handwritten cards we send stuffed
animals we make sure that everything is
always documented everything that's
verbal is also documented in writing so
it's like I'm going to tell you right
now what's going to happen next you're
also going to get an email after this
call that says everything that I'm
saying right now if you have questions
reference the email you're also going to
need a recording of This call that's
also going to be sent in a meal so if
you need to watch this again or show it
to your team so the next call is on
Tuesday that's the third so on there
you're gonna need these three things in
between now and then if you don't give
me those three things I can give you
access to this thing cool great it's
really just Clarity it also makes them
feel safe yeah right because people just
want to know